hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on for Andre and today we
have tons of before to talk about in a
new Assassin's Creed 4 honor
collaboration event going from December
20th to January 10th so as always like
the view do enjoy subscribe if you're
new I cover the informational side of
foreigner that being balanced changes
hero updates patch notes leaks
information to keep everyone up to date
on the world before honor let's get
started with today's video so first off
the Assassin's Creed event is gonna be
called for the Creed it is December 20th
to January 10th for the event there's
gonna be new music from past and current
Assassin's Creed games which is amazing
it's that girl that like does her little
opera sound in the back and I haven't
heard that [ __ ] in years and I'm in
tears bro I love that song so much and
for the background and the main menu and
the vs. all that stuff the background is
gonna be changed and it looks as almost
if we're in the Animus from the
Assassin's Creed games the minions are
changed for this event I had a double
take because I thought these were new
outfits but now they're actually minions
and they look really great so definitely
check that out when you're in those game
modes there's also a new game mode which
I'll go into in depth a little bit later
in the video on what it is and what it
entails but first up there's a couple
faction events that are going with it
the first event is to get the most
amount of matches completed for the
first faction get the most amount of
matches completed in the new game-mode
estación e eid templar e and then next
week is going to be the most the faction
with the most amount of takedowns
and then third week is going to be the
faction with the most amount of
executions there's also gonna be a new
arcade quest called project Odyssey and
in this one you're gonna be one of you
wanting a PK with extra damage in the
first phase next is gonna be a warden
with all unblockable z' and almost have
hyper armor third is a gladiator where
you have no guard stance and the
gladiator gains are drains more stamina
and does more block damage and then the
last one is where you fight a sent with
tons of unlockables and lots of damage
as well and that's gonna be the first
arcade quest now this is a three week
event so week two in week three are
gonna get progressively more harder as
you start going through the Animus and
doing all the simulations and according
to the developers you will actually be
fighting some of the characters from
Assassin's Creed whether that the Ezio
Caesar a any other character from the
Assassin's Creed games I don't know
exactly in specifics who they are but
there is going to be some Assassin's
Creed guests throughout the arcade quest
definitely check that out if you have
arcade
there's also going to be some new
lootable cosmetic items one of them is
going to be the outline for the faction
that you're on when you log on to the
game and some new weapons these weapons
were all inspired from Assassin's Creed
games conquers being from AC origins and
wardens being from the first ever
Assassin's Creed game etc etc you get
the point but the first group of weapons
is going to be R Musha Berserker
centurion and conch with gladiator
Highlander JJ and Kent say being next
third group is la bringer Nobu she knew
Shah and Hiroshi the fourth group of
weapons is PK Raider shaman and shinobi
second last will be Shaolin Shu goki T
on D in Belk and the two last is always
warden and warlord these do have an
assassin's creed vibe to them being
having the Templar or the Assassin's
logo on it and they're not entirely
flashy weapons they're more olden time
stuff and shamans is actually the
tomahawk from the third Assassin's Creed
game I like the little touch with that
one now I could be wrong because this
was actually never stated but I do
believe you can earn all of these
weapons at any Terp a type of rarity no
matter what so go for it there's also
going to be a [ __ ] ton of new content to
try to stay with me while I try to
explain this the new content that is
going to be released throughout this
event and I believe it's already gonna
be out now as we started cuz there is no
release date it just starts immediately
the new content is gonna be a mask
outfit the Odysseus of misty oh so I'm
pretty sure I butchered that name sorry
about that but it's the helmet where you
wear that you get from Assassin's Creed
Odyssey looks crazy good another emote
is the leap of faith where you jump into
a pile of hay very assassin's creed
esque like it the new elite ruler of
masses and champion of the people
outfits are also available for all
heroes and there's going to be a new
execution where you hit the opponent
jump on top of them and stab them in the
neck with the hidden blade from the
Assassin's Creed series cannot wait to
grab this execution now all of these are
what I would call unlockable types of
loot where you actually have to buy
these types of loot you cannot get these
from games you actually have to buy them
so both elite outfits the Templar and
assassin we saw in the trailer are 7k
the mask outfit is going to be 20,000
steal the leap of faith emo is going to
be 10k and the execution is going to be
7k steal so overall if you get all of
this this will most likely cost you over
40,000 steal but do not worry there is a
limited time bundle including the
scout fit the elite outfit the battle
outfit execution emo mood effects
embossing 'he's everything at which alta
and i'll get a little bit into detail
about what those emotes and effects are
that's all gonna be for 35,000 steals so
if you don't want to get everything with
this i definitely recommend getting the
bundle while you have the chance and the
price is always going to be affected so
if you already have one of the emotes
the price will go down because they
don't want you paying double for the
same thing but back to the other stuff
there is going to be two lootable emotes
that you will get from games and this is
going to be execution eamoinn oto you're
gonna have to get all three for them to
fully unlock you won't just have to get
one for the character and you get all
three you have to get three separately
and it's the same exact emo but the
bottom is different one of them is
either gonna have the Assassin's Creed
logo on the bottom or the Templar logo
at the bottom so if you're a Templar guy
if you're an assassin guy there's both
this both for both sides you're fine and
then there's also a new battle outfit
which looks really nice with the
Assassin's Creed logo on the front and a
new embossing as well with as well the
assassins and the Templars logo for some
embossing so if you want to rock that
group there's also going to be
specifically to only arcade and the new
game mode which we'll talk about in a
second which includes all the symbols
and logos from every single Assassin's
Creed game or comic so if you play those
game modes where they'd be arcade or
this new one you will have a chance of
getting some of the symbols from past
games and now the new game mode is going
to be called a sassy on EE Templar II
where you either are part of the
assassins or the Templars and you get to
have Ezio or Cesaro as your commander
the only thing you have to do it's based
off Dominion you have to capture the
middle lane which it which would be
point be whoever captures the middle
lane the opposing team's commander will
come out and like hey y-you capture my
stuff and then that team has to go
defend their commander or they or the
other team has to kill the opposing
commander now you can play this game
mode in PvP or PvE I it is a four before
mode and everything is on there is no
gear stats gone or anything like that so
it's entirely up to you on what
preference you want if you want to fight
bots if you don't want to fight bots
it's everyone's choice and I do want to
apologize that they have accidentally
misspoke in the beginning but to
actually win the game you need to reach
a thousand points then the enemy team
breaks and then you defeat all the
enemies it's very similar to Dominion
but the commanders are very helpful
because when you kill the commander you
score 300
poins which is almost half of the points
you need and usually by the time that
the commander would be spawning you
would probably have enough just to reach
a thousand from capturing him or killing
him and stuff like that so like I said
before make your minions go to the
middle make sure you own the middle of
the of the map have the commander come
out kill the commander to get 300 points
and then the nd way to actually end the
game is to reach a thousand have the
enemy team break and then defeat all of
them just like a normal Dominion at the
end and it's well a really quick tip on
the new game-mode there is no fall
damage so jump off all those walls jump
off the buildings the ledges all that
[ __ ]
you will not take any fall damage within
this game-mode so go wild with it yeah
but that guys is going to be the end of
it today hopefully guys do enjoy let me
know how excited you are for this
Assassin's Creed event if you've played
the Assassin's Creed games before if you
haven't I personally have only played a
few of them I stopped playing after
unity so I haven't experienced the new
modern Assassin's Creed games but I
still love the game so I'm very excited
to hop in record some gameplay do I have
all the fun with this game or play some
arcade this is gonna be a lot of [ __ ]
happening so definitely be excited for
that I'll have a guide out soon on how
to get all the new lootable stuff which
is what we talked about before that I
can show all of you on how to get that
the fastest so definitely on the lookout
for that if the guys like the V if you
do enjoy subscribe if you're new I cover
the informational site or for honor that
being balanced changes here are updates
patch notes and leaks all that good
stuff just to keep everyone up to date
on the world of war honor and do my my
two most recent videos will be on screen
if you guys do want to check that out
when that guys have a great stir today
thanks for watching the video and peace
out enjoy the event